hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier zu einem video
wo ich ein paar fragen beantworte
eigentlich sollte gestern das video
kommen weil ich hab gesagt dass gestern
zwei videos kommen am montag und
dienstag nichts kam allerdings habe ich
gestern auch nicht geschafft ein
bisschen leid dafür versuche ich heute
zwei videos machen also jetzt einmal
dieses fragen wie die heute ich am
nachmittag und heute abend noch mal so
ein video wo ich mein spiel spiele auf
einer website wieder sondern eines
lustiges spiel aber ich würde sagen ich
weiß gar nicht lange drum rum und wir
fangen direkt damit der ersten frage
lieber ein jammert nicht sehen oder nie
wieder internet also mal darauf bezogen
dass max nicht zu sehen so was ist wie
eine erfüllung eine belohnung quasi
etwas extrem tolles im leben wenn man
diese typ nicht sehen muss und ein jahr
internet so eine totale bestrafen das
will ich auf jeden fall sagen dass ich
lieber alia internet etwas falsch machen
wollte dass ich lieber internet hätte
und max nicht sehen würde so was glaubst
du in was für einer beziehung stehen
ananas und orange diese ganze sache mit
der ananas kam ihr auf das glaub ich
boxe hamsters damals weise dass meine
haare so sind wie so eine ananas ich
finde das zwar nicht aber irgendwie
denken dass sehr viel oder finden dass
ich weiß nicht und das mit der orange
war einfach weil ich das glaube ich mal
in einem twitter post geschrieben hatte
dass der mein lieblings mal hier sind
dann war das auch eine böse kommentare
lesen folge und dann habe ich das immer
so ein bisschen etabliert weil das mein
liebling smileys weil er so bunt ist
aber ich glaube in so einer richtigen
beziehungen stehen die jetzt so einander
nicht aber sind beide sehr schöne
smileys und sehr schöne früchte obst
gemüse keine ahnung denkst du nach dem
tod kommt etwas wie bist du gegenüber
dem tod eingestellt
das glaube ich schon mal gesagt dass ich
vor dem tod nicht wirklich angst habe
und mich darauf auch nicht wirklich
freude aber ich bin neugierig was danach
kommt weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
man denkt so normalerweise sagt man
danach kommt nix aber auch wenn nix ist
ist ja trotzdem irgendwas ist dann
stellt sich das so vormann ist irgendwo
im weltraum und über alles alles schwarz
und da ist einfach nichts aber ich weiß
nicht genannten stückchen weiter denkt
und nicht mal darüber nachdenkt oder
darüber gedanken
austauschen das fall was es eigentlich
heißt dass dort nichts ist das sms kann
nicht nicht sein weil man immer
irgendwie was was ist ich weiß nicht
wenn man so dass es hat man kann ich bei
keine ahnung ende die wahl hätte
zwischen eineinhalb millionen euro oder
5 jahre mehr zum leben was würdest du
wählen und warum wird auf jeden fall die
fünf jahre mehr zum leben nehmen weil
später denkt man sich warum haben die 15
millionen genommen hat sich vielleicht
ein sportwagen und yacht gekauft oder
irgendwie so aber ich würde auf jeden
fall die fünf jahre werde zum leben
nehmen wenn man sich dafür die 1 105
millionen euro entscheidet muss man
schon sehr sehr geldgeil sein wie bist
du auf den namen eines kanals gekommen
das ist wirklich die sache die ich am
häufigsten gefragt werde wie bin ich auf
meinen kanal namen gekommen bin ich auf
mein skin gekommen wie die wii ist
meinen kanal entstanden und so was alles
solche fragen sind alles fragen die am
meisten gestellt werden wie ich
allerdings schon so auf beantwortet habt
können natürlich einige nicht wissen
eventuell folgt wir diese person ist
schwitzen bei twitter oder so übrigens
twitter.com / von kraft darf als ihr
auch bei solchen fragen dabei sein wollt
könnt ihr mir dort gerne folgen
allerdings werden solche ganzen normalen
frage bin ich auf meinen kanal namen
gekommen auf meinen skin wie diese ganze
entstehungsgeschichte von mir zu youtube
zu minecraft ist ein rad beantworte ich
alles in meinem buch was irgendwann
september/oktober ging raus formierte
arbeiten werde dir derzeit dran aber
dieses thema dieses grundlegende sachen
über mich an meinen kanal haben wir
schon fertig dieser bereich dieser
rubrik das ist sehr cooler beantworte
ich das auf mehreren seiten fühle mich
also ein bisschen doof dass ich dieses
buch so oft erwähnt aber es ist halt
einfach derzeit das projekt neben
allgemeinen youtube-videos und uni das
projekt wo ich am meisten arbeit für
reinstecken und wo ich mich am meisten
darauf freue dass ich so was machen kann
und es tut mir leid heißt es viele so
auffassen so yao der macht auch immer
nur werbung für seines darf das von mir
aus kaufte es euch von mir aus nicht nur
diese fragen wird unter anderem auch
darin beantwortet wo kann man sich dann
ein buch kaufen
das war nicht extra ich habe einfach
diese mir diese frage gestern abend
ausgesucht und dann kamen diese frage
wohl direkt nach der frage zu meinem
kanal und dass ich jetzt darauf bezug
genommen habe auf mein buch das es dort
beantwortet wird tut mir leid also wo
kann man sich das buch kaufen wenn es
draußen ist kann man sich das denke ich
bei amazon kann man ist das kaufen
irgendwie so buchhandlungen die meyers
oder so oder halt wirklich einfach
irgendwie andere buchseiten wo man das
online bestellen kann aber das werde ich
noch ganz ganz viele rät wenn man jetzt
erstmal mit normalen fragen des dubai
waren drei dabei und wenn ja mit wem
freunde
ich werde nicht in sarow drei dabei sein
das kann ich schon mal sagen ich habe
auch schon fragen ob ich das nach außen
kommunizieren darf darf man man darf
auch sagen wann ist ein etwa startet und
so weiter und so fort also es wird
irgendwie im juli starten anfang juli
oder so oder mitte juli irgendwann im
juli auf jeden fall und der
aufnahmetermin der erste aufnahmetermin
von bahro 3 ist dann wenn ich in kanada
bin für sieben tage das ist ein großer
wunsch dass ich dorthin konnte das hat
jetzt ergeben auch in bezug auf youtube
weil da werden wir was cooles filmen und
so weiter dort bin ich auf jeden fall 78
tage in kanada und genau wenn ich mitten
in kanada bin und wahrscheinlich gerade
den jetlag überwunden habe ist diese
drei aufnahmen und ich kann nicht
einfach von kanada aus dass aufnehmen
deswegen tut es mir leid und wenn das
los gibt habt ihr dann wahrscheinlich
auf einem kanal und kanada videos zu
sehen und so weiter aber ich werde nicht
in faro drei dabei sein wieso kamen
gestern und vorgestern keine videos
jetzt gerade wenn ihr das video seht es
wahrscheinlich donnerstag aber diese
fragen wie der sollte eigentlich gestern
kommen also wieso kamen montag und
dienstag eine videos das ist ganz
einfach daran dass ich im urlaub bin ich
wollte eigentlich aus dem urlaub zwei
videos hochladen also sowas wie ein mal
wenn ich du wäre sache wo wir auf dem
virtuellen bundesliga event bahn von
kiefer dazu habe ich auch ganz so
schlimm dass computer online und ich
wollte noch so ein frage antwort video
vom strand machen oder so habe ich
allerdings beides zwar auch aufgenommen
allerdings war bei dem strand video der
ton mega kacke weil er so viel wind war
einfach und die zweite sache das
internet dort das hat richtig 1000
minuten gedauert um das hochzuladen also
ungelogen 1000 minuten und das war
einfach viel zu krasse gegenstand rechts
von ihr wird eine waffe bei einer zombie
apokalypse sein okay dagegen stand
rechts von mir ist ein taschentuch
ich weiß nicht in wie viel mir das bei
einer zombie apokalypse etwas geben
bringen wird aber
glaubst du an aliens wenn ja warum ich
glaube nicht wirklich an aliens aber ich
glaube schon dass es außerhalb der welt
oder beziehungsweise außerhalb der erde
auf irgendwelchen anderen planeten in
anderen galaxien in anderen milchstraßen
30 termine so gut aus mit sternen
astrologie dem ganzen staffel spielt mir
sehr sicher dass es irgendwo außerhalb
der erde sage ich es mal einfach auch
irgend einem anderen planeten noch leben
gibt da bin ich mir hundertprozentig
sicher weil wir haben noch lange nicht
alles vom universum herausgefunden was
es gibt und das ist auch so eine sache
da kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen das
ist alles hoch die sich unendlich große
stellt euch mal vor wenn man immer
weiter fliegt man es ist nie ende es
muss doch irgendwann mal ende sein mit
unserer welt 30 ich habe das so voll
schlecht vorstellen aber ich glaube auf
jeden fall dass es eben noch leben gibt
aliens würde ich das ganze allerdings
nicht nennen ja freunde das war es dann
auch hier heute mit dem videos wird mega
hell draußen ich hoffe dass solche
fertig werden wahrscheinlich in zukunft
auch für solche fragen sachen noch so
ein intro überlegen so ein kleines
kurzes eventuelle der ukulele gespielt
ich weiß nicht genau wie ich das mal
wieder wenn ihr bock auf mehr solche
fragen sachen hab dann könnt ihr gerne
bei twitter folgen oder ein daumen hoch
gehen dann sehe ich das ja auch und dann
sehen wir uns in einem nächsten video
wieder was heute abend noch kommen